j'accueille quelqu'un qui a peut-être
besoin de vous dites moi si joey starr
j'aurais
vous allez voir
est ce que tu as déjà été tentée par le
bout dit non je bois du roman l'a jamais
été tenté par la méditation
transcendantale d'abord non ya pas une
religion qui t'attend tu es un moment
non gros construit avec ma mère c'est
justement cette mère elle est croyante
ouais les catholiques bah ouais comme
tout les gens ont été jugées de la
colonie me fais pas non non non merci
tat j'ai pas besoin garde-fous quoi
ouais moi j'ai foi ou gentiment touré en
moi le doudou ça peut faire du bien
arriver à un homme sûrement arriver à se
détacher des désirs je mangeais pas nous
ça va gentiment gentiment le temps
beaucoup plus incongrue mais alors c'est
toujours le patron du boss le collectif
boss le boss du boss à la fin bon score
en plus un premier jour mon score ça
marche bien
ouais ça va alors le nouvel opus du
collectif bosse donc un s'appelle opus 3
pts mais c'est le troisième
on a compté
tqs
en particulier
voilà quand sa belle constat montre
intéressant mais voilà je suis là je
vais aller retour à paris toulouse je
suis prêt par la ba ouais mais tu m
appelles dadou à la réalisation pour ça
je vais là-bas je vais chez lui dans son
fief ouais mais ça avance je pense que
on se reverra ça pour des 2500 et je la
regardais mon nom comme d'habitude non
oued en urgence 30 ans à dire qu'on
démarre avant mais on fait tous les
jours
ouais voilà dans l'urgence de l'actuelle
alors va passer en revue le rap français
savent pas où ça en est là la rumeur
1 c'est bon la rue main c'est bien booba
mais lui un pas mais là je peux enfin
bon c'est pourquoi pourquoi je veux lui
même papa arménien un devis sans fil non
justement
je suis arrivé en retard la première
m'ont dit les lettres qu'il est le délai
d un voyage essai assassin
non pourquoi la mer ainsi que l'avenir
reste est officieusement je trouve qu'il
va mieux ouais ministère amer qui se
reforment d'ailleurs tout proche n'a
rien à [ __ ] en train de refaire
bassiste mes achats qui se monte à orner
des 300 signatures la nuance titre à toi
quand il sait qu en direct est là
kool shen wei suppl à trois jours tu
disais musicalement ça ne plaît pas du
tout mais je me dis ah ouais super à
oued aïssi non musicalement j'ai un
problème avec moi c'est un peu de la
musique d'ascenseur mais sinon c'est un
des mecs qui étaient venus pour moi
c'est vrai qu'il écrit bien et tu
trouves que ces mélodies c'est un peu
légères et faciles non c'est pas les
mélodies slaves l'épreuve derrière quoi
je trouve
ouais tu trouves les livres ouais ça
c'est sûr c'est pas ça quand ça commence
là
je
ça me rappelle un peu l'album de
christine deviers joncour la cour
c'est le même genre de groupe et ouais
ouais bon continuer même si jean gabin
alors tu es sympa comme tout il peut
être sympa sur le plateau de télé sinon
chez nous là à la voir c'est une [ __ ]
on as marque de vélos des vélos le fait
n'a pas dit quand il veut je l'attends
sur scène pourquoi parce que n'existent
assez inexistant ben je sais pas moi
j'ai plein de gens qui l'ont vu faire
juste son morceau je t'emmerde
ouais c'était n'importe quoi un morceau
il a du mal moi moi le minimum juste un
coeur tu choisiras kong
quant à 10 est un rappeur avec un string
sur la tête sourire c'est pas très sympa
comme commises et booba quoi sont ils se
mouiller sur la morgue
même si jean gabin bien même temps même
si gérard philipe
c'est pas bon pied le cinéma aussi ah
bon tu va tourner en février 2005
ouais je peux en parler d'un truc j'ai
eu chaud face le pitch savoir ses quatre
filles sublimes transport qui sont
toujours en bikini campagne braquage et
humilient les hommes elles s'envolent
pour la réunion
et là tout le sens réunionnais elle
tombe sur un mec s'appelle mustapha
qu'est joué par toi et tu tiens en otage
marjolaine et elles veulent libérer
marjolaine s'appelle claudette la tour
voilà cheval pitch ça va être bien
peeters initial et vanessa d'amour je
pense
le stockholm ça te dit rien mais je pas
non j'ai pas lui moi j'ai rien vu encore
ouais je t'apprends je fais ça doit se
faire sous peu mais sont février alors